I read that fasting naturally increases HGH, which is human growth hormone in this article
written by a functional medicine doctor.
I know in your blog, it says not to take human growth hormone because it causes cancer
to grow in alert ears with apoptosis.
How is it that HCG, HGH, generated by fasting is good for cancer?
Fasting also increases HGH, one just curious as to the difference.
So, yes, fasting can increase all sorts of different growth factors.
It does increase HGH, one production too, but typically only after you fast it.
At least the studies that I've written is after you do a 24 hour fast.
So, anything fasting less than 24 hours, typically we tell people is perfectly fine for cancer patients.
If you're fasting more than 24 hours, you do risk raising your HGH, one levels and other growth
hormones as well. That's part of the benefit of fasting if you don't have cancer.
So, if you don't have cancer and you're going on and you've done some fasting,
you never say to go, oh, that's three day faster, seven day faster, 10 day faster, longer than that.
If you've never fasted at all, fasting is something you need to work into.
But we have had cancer patients that have done a 21 day fast or a 10 day fast prior to
starting with us or even after starting with us and they seem to do real well.
So, there's the card evidence that's out there is that after 24 hours of fasting,
you do raise human growth hormone levels and IGF-1 levels.
Therefore, we tend to tell people that you should limit your fast to less than 24 hours.
That's typically an advice on fasting.